one of my favourite pastimes
is to come up with new ways to trick my
children into eating their vegetables
and would you believe
that this spaghetti and meatballs has
12 hidden veggies in it
They didn't believe it either because
I didn't tell them and they didn't guess
In the Ninja Foodi Hot Cold Blender
I put onion garlic
carrot courgette
mushrooms and spinach alongside a little bit of oil
and I blended that on medium speed until the paste came together
in a large mixing bowl I popped a kilo of ground beef mince
3/4 cup of breadcrumbs
two tablespoons of dried oregano and dried mixed herbs
1/4 cup of Parmesan
my egg and my veggie paste
give it a mix and then roll it out into balls
I'm only using half of my mixture
and the other half is going in the freezer for later in the week
and I'm popping the meatballs in the fridge while I get started on my sauce
we've got onion garlic
capsicum mushrooms a can of chopped tomatoes and some fresh parsley
I've also added dried oregano
mixed herbs and salt and pepper
measured with my heart
and I put my Ninja Foodi on the sauce/dip setting
so it's gonna do all the work
cooking and blending it for me
while I get cracking on cooking the rest of the dinner
and I've noticed that this blender has an ice cream setting
a cocktail setting and a frozen drink setting in case I wanna make a Margarita
which I do
I do wanna make a Margarita
once my sauce was done I just poured it over my browned meatballs
then I popped my meatballs and sauce on top of a bed of spaghetti
topped with Parmesan and some Italian flat leaf parsley
this meal went down a treat
and they didn't even know they were eating veggies